hey there townscapers and welcome to the
channel as always thank you for stopping
by if it's your first time here of
course i want to give you a really big
welcome i thank you so much for coming
by and i hope you enjoyed this video
today so townscaper got an update and it
is really really awesome there are a few
changes that they made to the game to
the ui some new functionality features
and new sound effects so i'm really
excited about it let's just get into it
uh the first and most important thing
about this there are new sound effects
uh there is now music playing in the
background when you select a file to
open and also when you load that file
and it's amazing it's just so beautiful
and it's so soothing and i just really
really like it and there's also an ocean
ambiance in the background as well um so
the whole time that you're building
you're listening to the ocean so listen
to this
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
so i i just really really enjoyed that
it's
it's so relaxing and it just really sets
the mood for townscaper in my personal
opinion i love it so much
but let's go to the next thing so if you
go to the menu you'll notice that
there's a settings button under new and
open and if you open settings you see
you have the usual full screen the pin
ui and the language and volume options
what's new is the lock 30 frames per
second the anti-aliasing and the
keyboard and mouse and gamepad controls
and the touch controls options i assume
that 30 frames per second in
anti-aliasing is mainly for console but
i'm sure it can help on pc and possibly
mobile as well um obviously touch
controls would be for touch screen
platform so mobile and switch and one of
my other favorites is the option to use
a game pad also a feature that will come
in handy with the switch and i'm really
excited about that also now you can make
custom textures for townscaper i i
really wanted some new colors but it
would be nice to add like different
stuff onto the buildings like vines and
stuff like that so i will have a lot of
fun with this one and i hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did like this
video please share the video with people
if you think they would enjoy it also
check out my description and again thank
you so much for stopping by i can't say
that enough and i'll see you all next
time
[Music]
you